[Music]
you look amazing I've never seen you
dress up like I do don't I you look
terrific
now that you can I tell you something I
know what you're getting at and I
probably should put some of the rumors
to rest
they've been swirling around I might as
well announce it here I've had a little
work done
oh you had you had work done I did I get
a little fresher up every time I come
out well when am I talking about they
did a lot they did an eye job I got a
nose job facelift I had breast reduction
and penis reduction which I did I did
not think was possible really no
seriously
really well over the years that boogers
been whittled down to practically
nothing seriously the point where I'm
saying why bother right first my wife
reached that point a long time it was
right after the birth of our second
child really yeah it's been a while for
you see it's been a while you had this
procedure done I did I did it was a long
procedure too I think I was sleeping for
a long time and under anesthesia so I
don't really know everything they did
it's hard to tell I was out like three
or four days I think you're out for
three or four days I think all of this
work done I think you can tell you all
could see the glow that I have I think
you have a before picture somewhere
before picture you before you had all
this work done right
and I think you have you know the after
shot there okay no you can see it that's
a just a whole news I think you're just
smiling in one photo I know you know
they say and it kind of goes against my
instincts too that the best plastic
surgery you can't tell ya at all and
that's apparently what my doctor says
also and it's also the most expensive